Especially the bottom conference,
it was above all to listen to you,
so that we have 1 vision uh Exactly the most uh precise on uh its needs.
How they're going to evolve over the next few years The weather,
we've seen uh The numbers are there,
uh it's been uh Significant this year,
it'll probably be even more so over the uh Next few years So
uh this observation uh Global warming,
dust that will certainly kill itself,
uh it requires 1 collective uh effort.
How can we optimize how we can save on the scale of our households,
on the scale of our local authorities,
also on the scale of our exports uh Harry Potter,
also on the scale of the world uh industrial to ensure
that Well thistion uh also allows us,
and this is one of the elements that I would like to prove,
uh to innovate,
uh to anticipate And that,
I do not doubt that the fruit of your reflection,
of our collective reflection uh pushes us uh quickly to have even more common,
to have effectively this shared vision.
Uh Water on the scale of our territory.